yeah things gonna be tough i'm coming
from iran like everyone says that
because they cannot committed to this
just finished your phd yeah so i want to
ask you a couple of questions oh
why do you think someone should choose
computational neuroscience now that you
finished why shouldn't
but
yeah
because i think um so there are lots of
things that um
you know you have curiosity about like i
don't know like things on their oceans
like things in a space like um things
like how the like the um sub ottoman
atomic call you know a particle moves
like it just like it just brings your
own curiosity like you can kind of own
the question there right so i think
competition or like at least
neuroscience is one of them and for me
like why competition neuroscience
because a lot i like to like find um
like i i want to quantize the things
that we think it's a qualitative
it's it's really enjoyable to see like
measures for something that we think we
cannot measure yeah right yeah so for me
that part was really interesting and
thanks okay so i was also wondering like
for you i know you're a really
productive person like i know you work
really hard and sometimes kind of crazy
hours
um but i was wondering like what does an
average day for you look like and how do
you stay so productive you know i think
it's just like
it almost applies to everyone like we
don't work on a uniform distribution
hours right so like and then like like
but some people have this like i don't
know like as something like the gaussian
you know average but for me like i think
just like i have these sparks
so so it's just like when we are talking
about average it's kind of like i cannot
say that in average but uh
you know like of course i can take an
average but i mean
uh then but then the hour's gonna be so
low
so i'm not gonna say how much but then
the thing yeah i actually wanted to ask
you this especially like because you're
a
foreigner in a new country ray and also
a woman
in science and i kind of wanted to ask
you like how is it to do it as a
foreigner in the netherlands do you
think um
i think in netherlands i was so lucky
like i had some like um
unfortunate incidents like for example
my my first
project stopped
in phd
like the first phd i was doing here but
then um
it was really easy like it wasn't like
um i'm coming from iran like really
different culture and everything
but here i didn't feel um that much of
you know like cultural shock and
everything like i was yeah i mean like
but i mean like this is a this is my
personal experience right like it cannot
be like um extended to everyone but i'm
saying like this is a really safe
environment like in academia like
everyone is
really supportive they really trying to
help you and boost your you know
confidence like do that do this and if
you don't know something people willing
to help you and i think that's really
important and um
of course like moving from uh like
really different place to another you
all you you should know like things
gonna be tough right so there are lots
of things that you you need to think
about um ahead but um like
when i'm comparing myself to my other
friends like they are living in
different
living in different countries i think i
was lucky because in like the places
where i was in netherlands like always i
had these warm feelings of support like
yeah and like looking back then on your
phd because now you're a doctor right
you just graduated oh my god um looking
back like do you think you would have
done something different or if you could
start again like
not to start again but
just kidding yeah uh yeah of course i i
think like um even like after six months
i was thinking oh okay i could do that
different
so okay so um
there are like some details like i was
doing everything in matlab back then um
yeah i know it sounds really outdated i
think the last time i touched matlab was
three years ago but i remember like the
time i started my phd like i was i had
this experience with mata for i don't
know 15 years so yeah so for me it was
really easy and then when i started my
first project i could finish it finished
like in
three four months and then i started
doing uh python like and everyone uh was
saying back then like if you're
expecting c plus plus a matlab python
gonna be so easy so i thought just
syntax so i actually didn't um didn't
learn it like didn't yeah didn't uh make
time to you know look at the
the structure of this uh language so
then i was just doing everything by
trying her so like
[Laughter]
so it took me a long time to you know
like
avoid some mistakes and uh like i think
it slowed me down a bit but i mean like
besides these sort of things i think um
i would have been more structured so
like i like from the beginning it like
this is the thing
i think everyone knows it's really
difficult to stick to it yeah so like
yeah so i mean like um
you know how you know spend a little
more time you know like when you are
like um coding put everything on github
you know like have a good name you know
like don't you know like
like i have some quotes it's like paper
method section three three two two and
then new you know like those crazy names
and then
i like and i know everyone is saying
that and i think now that like i'm one
of the people who says that i just
realized everyone says that because they
cannot committed to this
they want to you know like find some
people yeah they find some people to do
that because it's perfect but i know
it's really annoying but yeah in the end
when your project getting bigger and
bigger and bigger it kind of uh
occupying lots of your you know process
power like in your brain because you
like you have to think about lots of
things when you go back there you have
to when you like after two months for
example you you want to do something in
your um you know like in your project
it's not that easy you know like we this
is the problem we have yeah so yeah no
yeah for sure so like if you then would
give advice to like new students
if they want to enter this field and
they come from a different background
like you really like because you're also
you didn't start as a neuroscientist
right like what would you say is
important to learn or to to acquire to
get into neuroscience and to yeah i
think it's it's really depending on from
what angle they want to enter right so i
think for me um when i was looking back
like if i want if i knew like i'm i'm
gonna you know do things in this field
i would um i would study something more
solid like
math yeah
because you know like it gives you more
insights
and um
yeah
really solid foundation so because
it also gives you some
sensation how to you know work later so
i'm coming from engineering background
we had enough mass but then it's not
something like we are using everything
for applications right so then like um
i'm not really using that for uh for the
things i'm doing
but there was there was times that i was
thinking
you know if i had this knowledge in here
i could have used that better like i
like i already like
i already know different kind of masks
so i mean like i could have you know
like i could have something like this
yeah and um i think this is a
i think we should spend more
time on fundamental science from like
from the bachelor and then in master and
then when you
then it's it's gonna get really easier
when you're gonna go to
interdisciplinary project and this is uh
something i think this is really
important because like in the beginning
you still don't know you know what
directions you want to go like if this
is
i'm just saying that because it did
apply to me because i changed my
direction a lot so i yeah i i studied
electro engineering during the my
bachelor i did work on lasers and then
for master i was looking at integrated
ice like integrated um circuits so like
high frequency ics and then i also did
something in uh plasma physics and then
uh like um
like medical physics like really
different things and then like
neuroscience and then again ar
reinforcement lots of things like from
with lots of
different directions but then i was
thinking like if i if i had a solid
background on something
even chemistry i don't know even like
physics something like this yeah then
like you could go further i mean like to
school math yes
yeah yeah exactly yeah so but i mean it
it does help you like in future if you
want to go to different directions yeah
and like i think this is important for
you know essay in science yeah for sure
for sure
okay and then i want to ask a little bit
more on your personal experience right
so like you did your phd you're finished
um like if you look back what was the
most positive thing you think and what
did you learn that's kind of not science
related right during my phd
um
i think it's positive yeah i think that
the fact that um you know during your
phd you are spending so much time on
um some projects and then the chance of
meeting interesting people in terms of
you know like they they also working on
the same project or something similar
you can meet lots of interesting people
and
like it gives you joy you know like
yeah to you know to have some like you
don't look
you know
bearded because you know like there are
some people that they can't understand
why you are excited about this thing so
that's i like to share this excitement
lisa you are a football fan yeah but for
uh
yeah but for your own team so it's just
it
it makes you really happy and then i
don't know when people acknowledge your
work like when you're randomly like
you're in a talk and randomly people you
know cite you like it's it's yeah it's
like wow you know like for a moment you
feel like you feel really important but
because you know like we all know how
you know science developed like yeah
it's like a small breaks people's work
and then it feels suddenly you feel
really big like oh i'm part of it i did
something yeah yeah so it just you know
it's gonna it doesn't gonna last like
you know like it's gonna disappear for a
second but then you feel a bit important
like you are part of this human you know
uh history of you know science so i
think that part like it gives you at
least for me it gave me um personal
satisfaction
and of course i think
like
we all
i think most of us when we are in
science we want to solve a puzzle right
so like this dissolving puzzle like
every time you solve a puzzle it gives
you a joy
and
of course this is like
this joy is different from like
publishing a paper or you know like
getting citations and those even getting
compliments from your supervisor it's
just it's a really
different pure
joy so i think that that part is really
like it's really rewarding yeah but i
should say it doesn't happen often
because
it's hard yeah like sometimes you wrote
like i don't know four weeks on your
quote and you cannot find the bug and
then you you realize okay you know like
this is the reason it's not a puzzle
it's not a real puzzle but you see feel
it you feel joy but then i you feel also
bad for yourself so
yeah so yeah you have that yeah true so
nice okay so for the last thing i kind
of want to ask you is like of course
your future plans right because you're a
full doctor now and you're very famous
already
what are you gonna do after and what are
your big plans and so um
as you know i'm already at ucl so i'm
doing my postdoc
so um
i think i was in science for a long time
i know i like to be a scientist i i like
i like to say you know being scientist
but um i think it just for me the the
interesting thing is a project so i want
to have impact i don't want to be like
someone who does things and then because
you know he sure he can
so um i want to go to the direction that
i can have impact i'm like
i'm not just talking about impact on
society i'm just talking about impact in
science so yeah so like uh of course you
know like when you
you when you are part of you know
scientific community you are gonna have
impact on society but i'm just saying
like i wanna
have more focus on that like i want to
build up
something there
in uh you know scientific community yeah
create your own niche inside yeah yeah
yeah
yeah oh great okay miriam thank you i
will show also some footage of like
marion's graduation day because it will
was so nice and
yes yeah she's she was one of my friends
but like
the one who you know like walked ahead
yeah but yeah but walk ahead but it used
to be defending you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah with the sword and everything
yeah that's all yeah
yeah but it was really fun to have you
as my partner yeah
[Music]
are you nervous
no i'm really fine you're calm
down
[Music]
right here
here is a little bit of ugly room but
still yeah this is like
this is like a killing room
yeah
watch out here
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
are you ready to be a pair nymphs
i think miriam's honor
so
take your time
that's what she said i'm a doctor from
university
i would like to defend public
minds rotation entitled
an exploration of norwegian signature of
psychiatric disorders
[Music]
okay yeah thank you
okay guys thank you for joining and
see you next time bye